you've been there yeah oh yeah and it's
surprising yeah surprise talk about on
the show yeah that's exactly what
we're doing oh we got our best way to
put it well
are we rolling we live i'm wearing a
shirt hold on wait
i gotta start off with something to give
brian what i just i
was thinking about when i was in philly
you know and i bought something like
really expensive
you're glad he's bad i'm glad he's back
you know like and you've done you know
like i said you've always said kind
words about me
and uh so i just wanted to pass this on
to you it's worth
a lot okay how much we talking you think
what is it
oh that's a british rookie rookie card
dude some say that's priceless oh i know
lebron james card went from five million
okay
i'm trying not to cry right now and i
finally have
something i can wear around my neck and
that yeah and it's
exactly so that means i never have to
take it off i might have an
ingrained in my skin that's him fighting
the voice bodied up there
you're botted up you had a different
nose 2010.
you got the stats on the back well no no
that's that's my first
the technical first ufc fight although i
beat up the biggest change
with him is his nosey posey he's got his
teeth used to be a little more pointy
and then
crow cop went i don't like your nose and
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna take this
croatian elbow
and i'm gonna yeah look at what i can do
i got in a heated argument by the way
heater argument with a dude i don't even
know who was like your boy gets his lips
done
and i went excuse me excuse me and he
goes your boy he gets
in his lips and i go like no no that's a
story he told when he had to get his
lips stitched and he goes yeah i know
but he gets it he gets stuff in his lips
i go i go no he doesn't i
now i'm arguing with a fan because i'm
like
no he doesn't and i got i got a little
in his face he goes yeah he does
yeah he is i go you don't know anything
i've known him forever he goes
you can google the pictures i go no you
can't yeah yeah
i got back then i got wait was this why
you're on stage no
no in fact it was when i after my show a
guy said that one time
and i'm like i'm i'm having a heated
argument
i would have said you know how i know
you're gay because you think brenda has
lip fillers and you stare at his lips
and then you went through photoshop
and tried that that's right i hate that
i'm looking at him we gotta we all got
big lips there
you're right yeah your top lip could you
well that's his face i've heard that
that is his name
no you got the brian gumbel top lip well
as you get older apparently you're
you're i think your lips get smaller
your your ears get bigger you lose
muscle mass and i've heard your penis
shrinks yeah and i'm not kidding
i know the ears thing but i know your
nose and ears get bigger or you see
do your ears get bigger and nose or does
your face just kind of small stay small
probably all three probably all over the
place
and i cut my own hair and i'm having a
problem you've been cutting your own
house stop taking propecia
uh because i ran out and i'm clearly
losing more
hair on the top my dome at what point do
you think you're gonna shave at all dude
well at what point do you think i'm
gonna come here with a full head hair
and act like nothing happens
i pray for that day yeah because there's
a guy named champagne that's his last
name oh champagne
out of out of jason diamonds the guy who
did my eyes oh that's the kardashian
doctor
yeah yeah now now his partner uh
apparently the best when it comes to
hair restoration so
don't do so if i look like foreign
individual hairs now
individual grafts i bet it takes forever
because you
you can definitely if you have enough
money like floyd mayweather you've seen
his hair lately
full set of hair didn't theo do that
he took it from the back and he feels
like friends well theo's problem is he
had so much
yeah he's self-conscious that he thinks
eventually he's gonna lose it
so he gets procedures done just to be
safe excuse me and it made his forehead
it's called crazy yeah
it's called crazy it's called crazy yeah
yeah
look at leah floyd there now could he
look any more like adrien broner he
didn't
need hair floyd doesn't need he looks
terrible with hair but you don't look
weird bald
either though you've never seen him all
right yeah he he
you shaved it why showed up well shaved
and bald's different yeah
i think you would look ridiculous yeah i
think
like a loyal yam that's just life that's
what happens
why can't you just yeah like if i'm
balding black guys are gonna go
black guys are cool white guys if
they're bigger look cool bald like jeff
bezos
travolta looks good john travolta had a
lot of work done what does he look like
now
take a look at john travolta now yeah he
went bald he looks very good
and he looks and that the his skin that
got tightened around his face
now kind of cool he looks great yes he
does he looks cool huh
oh he looks real cool by the way he's uh
he's older
what do you mean what work did he have
done well he had his face oh okay yeah
you can see
his hair was dope what do they call that
crow the trophy
crow's feet crow's feet on the inside
yeah yeah he had good hair though huh
yeah didn't he
yeah it was fake hair though you think
yeah see but that's all
you that's what they said about steve
harvey too they said his hair that
little flat top he had for like
so long they said that was fake i heard
his mustache is fake no
yeah it's like i heard it's like mr
potato head you spread there's no bro
no i heard that that's how my lip rumors
are yeah right yeah i heard it's like mr
potato head just [ __ ]
no there's no way oh uh
b i was in kentucky dude actually i
could live there it'll surprise me i
could live there
all right there was time grass now hold
on i'm hyped up when are you getting a
little cat
go cats no hold on go cats you got to
take that back for a second why
because i wasn't there in the winter no
you couldn't
you couldn't live there any time and i
love slow i love that you like kentucky
i love that you're saying that i loved
it you were there for three days
you saw those green hills kentucky
or is the green hills other way both yes
and uh it's a beautiful place
that'll surprise you you're expecting
terrible and you weren't
oh this is correct right so that's what
we're going to talk about
you could you want you had living as a
gentleman on a horse farm with your
whiskey
yeah or no no i just like the big big
long grass lawns
like everyone had long lawns so i'm
getting older i really appreciate a nice
green one well you got you got a couple
athletes for
for kids and they would love those lawns
and those kids run
and they got some explosions they're
like gazelles yeah look at you
you touch the nose you know i touched it
so much the horse bit me
the horse bit you it bit me on the
shoulder and it hurt but i played it off
like i was like
and then i literally went in the barn
was like
did it bruise you up you look like a man
horse right there i know right
me and the horses have the exact same
face and that's fine
and we have the same nose and eyes
that's fine your hair is
only your face is just a tad and shorter
than that horse
yeah that's a long if you elongated my
face that yeah i look like a horse
that's you if you started going
that makes sense how is the whiskey
uh you know buffalo chase is so big and
famous now
we uh no one pre-planned it because
that's my team and so we go up there and
i go hey we're looking for a tour
and uh though he goes oh your friend
charlie yeah she goes yeah fans and i'm
like oh cool
and then she goes yeah cool we've been
sold out for six months now since we've
opened
oh and she was yeah but there's a gift
shop right there for you guys and you
try something there i go
okay we'll go to the gift shop we go to
the gift shop
the line is oh i don't know like splash
mountain disneyland sure and i asked her
how long do you think this line's going
to take she goes you're like at least an
hour sweetie oh well i'm not going to
wait now for anything
if john mayer was playing live in there
i wouldn't wait in this lineup
i'm going to leave now so we left and
you know jay he's a real tourist
and he wants to sit there in line with
you well jay here's the thing you're on
vacation
i got to work so i'm like on my feet all
day doing this i'm leaving
so i had i i'm doing radio john
holgram's with brady and it's
my favorite john holcomb's radio station
yeah yeah when uh
arizona he's the best he could be a cop
homebrew could be
did he open for us at the orpheum is
that that guy uh no
uh yes he's that he's the m.c yeah not
open but he was the mc for 98.
he's phenomenal yeah yeah john is like
you know yeah radio's dead
brady who i love who's also his coach he
kills it yeah rachel's dead
brady says right baby no listen radiant
yeah they listen to homebrew but still
number one in phoenix yeah yeah sure 17
listeners
no no i'm just kidding no five million
people please be real no there's a ton
yeah
but brady says to me and you'll
appreciate that he goes
hey uh would you like to
come to the zoo and feed
um feed animals you can feed some
animals behind the scenes this is a
grown man
asking you another woman i i got excited
without thinking like you just did with
kentucky and i went
yes i i do that i go sure or please
it was even through a text it was i'm
more ruthless i went please with a cat
with an
exclamation oh wow so he goes wow i'll
set it up yeah but it gets worse so he
goes
he sets it up for whatever reason i i'm
supposed to do a podcast with sugar sean
o'malley
and there's a welch yep and i text sugar
shawn and i go
you guys want to come to the zoo and
feed animals
and sugar shawn and tim go yeah oh
interesting yeah i go maybe we'll get
some content out of it but we'll do some
videos and stuff like that so there we
are
oh wow oh that's pretty badass that's
dope yeah
yeah just file it off get a small sauce
just that much right there
oh my my hand smells like rhino breath
exactly
are they friendly yeah
[Laughter]
oh i haven't sexted her yet
look at him look at how
sean looks like a native american
transitioning into takashi's six days
by the way is that homeburg by the way
he fights at 135 and look at how big he
is
he's pretty tall yeah
if you go to the zoo with your family
never
show your friends videos or pictures of
you at the zoo no no you're because i've
been to the zoo no you're right i can
google
that rhino and i got there and guess
what that's rule number one
i'm sitting here online
is there anything worse when your
friends go on vacation like dude check
out i was in hawaii i'm like
were there hot chicks with their tits
out because if not
i don't want to see i don't want to see
it how about when people are flying the
plane
and they take a bit oh my god the clouds
when they when they film it like the
clouds can't see your phone
don't do that whoever you send that to i
just did them a favor
well that was that's a i wanted that's a
very boring video but but
here's the worst video here's the thing
about it we get there and we went and
saw penguins we saw the
there was a baby penguin that they held
up next to me so i saw penguins
one had one was 30 missing an eye oh
missing an eye lost his eye and was just
like
well they live in an aquarium with water
and he's just in fake rocks
and they all stand like this in arizona
like that and that's their life for
their whole life and this guy's been
there for 30 years with one eye
miserable whatever he did in his past
life bad life that's a bad life bad life
and then we saw porcupine didn't get to
touch him it was a marsupial
it was a an arboreal porcupine lives at
night who gives a [ __ ] yeah too much
and then was the guy way too was the
tour guide way too into the animals
the people that work there are very into
the animals the thing is
then we fed a giraffe and sugar went
sugar goes i'm bored
and i go yeah i'm sorry i'm sorry i made
you guys hold on
here it was 45 minute drive i had to
wake up early well dude that's like
that's like it's in uh
in kentucky jay goes oh you know jay
he's like yeah he's like i got this
email this lady wants to go to her
horse farm and blow i go how far is he
it's about 40 minutes but it's supposed
to be pretty cool
so i gotta forcefully go okay guess
we're doing that well they have at least
have whiskey and bourbon for us to try
to
i guess we'll do that today so me jay
and justin drive out there
40 minutes we drive out there we get out
of the car
and we're looking at the horses and 10
minutes into i look at jego
you good where do i go this is all we're
gonna do today
there's gonna be more horses just like
these nothing this
this is the white horses not all white
horses all right one picture with the
brown horse we're
seeing there while they're they're
teaching us about this this we i fed
a porcupine a little piece of corn and i
just i went like that
and i was sitting there as me and sean
and and tim welton
and everybody and the and my buddy brady
i love god bless but he loved it because
he had his 11 year old daughter there
and he goes
i go we gotta actually get back podcast
and uh buddy goes
yeah but do you guys want to feed the
pig pig me hippo uh some lettuce
and i oh at the same time we might be
into no
no we're good i'm good though yeah you
know what i kind of regret it cause i
wanted to i would have liked the
yeah i would have been doing that hippo
i kind of a white hippo
it was a pygmy that'd be cool oh small
hip-hop yeah yeah that'd be cool
yeah they only get like uh oh that's
cool
dude out of all the [ __ ] oh my god yeah
yeah i said yeah to that the one thing
that things cute as [ __ ]
now i regret it i could have fed it a
whole head of lettuce
is that lizzo i don't know anyways the
thing is
is i love i love hippos dude
dude that that would have been the best
thing possible
oh but yeah but by the way oh those are
gorgeous
though gorgeous though they are they're
cool
no that sounds weird what do you mean
they're not gorgeous
no no he's cute he's cute they're
gorgeous gorgeous like if you see a bit
you know something colorful
but that's how they look that's what
they're supposed to look like what
animal they're
most closely related to not a rhino nope
because they're in water right they
chill in water a lot what is it
hold on don't tell me i know i hate i
hate your little quizzes no they go
under then
they hang under water wait you say give
me a hint
i like where you're going and also
another man what hangs in the water is a
whale
they're close to a whale oh i would have
never got that
i don't know because i was about to say
squirrel or some [ __ ] like
i know yeah brandon probably already
looked that up or heard me say that
before but i like that i don't think
that's
that no that's where i was going i don't
know hey i didn't even know they're
close to a whale uh
i had the best philly cheesesteak you
went to angelo's and
i tell you dog oh my god you've been
there angelo you haven't been angelos
in philly let's take a little break with
the kid and chappelle lacy on fighter
and the kids cause this
what kids big names are headlining this
weekend's ufc 262 card
we talking about michael chandler
charles oliveira tony ferguson dariush
we got it all this saturday and you can
bet and make bank with the official
sports book
of the ufc we're talking about freaking
draftking sportsbook that's right and
they have a great offer for you this
weekend's fight ufc 262 you bet
one dollar to win 100.
that's crazy man all you do is just pick
the main event fighter you think will
win
and draftking sportsbook will give you
100 to one odds on that fighter
that's right bet one dollar on a select
fighter if they win
you win 100 there's no better way to put
your mma knowledge to the test
than with draftkings draftkings is safe
secure and reliable
you can deposit withdrawal your funds
whenever you want download the top rated
draftking sportsbook app now use the
promo code fighter
when you sign up to turn one dollar into
100 when you bet on
a main card fire to win place your bet
and watch the fist fly this weekend ufc
that's code fighter to turn one dollar
into 100
all right for limited time only at
draftking sportsbook must be 21 or older
new jersey indiana pennsylvania only
new customers only restrictions apply
see draftkings.com sportsbook for
details
gambling prom call 100 gambler or an
indiana winning 109 with it
one thing about me that i got that dad
life man all i care about is a green
lawn i love green lawns that's why i
love lexington kentucky there's so many
freaking lawns man
and you want to see your lawn thrive
and you need a custom lawn care plan
that's right from sunday
sunday is more than just a lawn care
product it's a custom lawn care plan
with a variety of ways to help you grow
a beautiful lawn is there anything
better than that green lawn
god dang man i love it green man
and if you don't need weeds all right
you need you don't want weeds you want
pest control
uh sunday got you covered man sunday
makes take care of your lawn so much
easier
all you got to do is go to getsunday.com
you put in your home address
and their free lawn analyst tool kit
will
take care of the rest it just takes
seconds sunday uses soil and climate
data
to create a tailored nutrition plan so
you get the stuff your lawn needs all
right
and nothing it doesn't sunday explains
exactly what you need to get and why
everything is waiting at your
door when you need it all you gotta do
is attach the ready to use pouch to the
garden hose and spray
lawn care used to take up the whole day
not anymore every time about 15 minutes
green lawn man my line's looking better
than ever because of sunday
let's sunday take the guesswork out of
growing a greener more beautiful lawn
this spring you dads out there know what
i'm talking about
visit getsunday.com fighter get 20 off
your custom line plan
at checkout that's 20 off custom plan at
dot com getsunday.com fighter all right
hey i didn't even know they're close to
a whale uh
had the best philly cheesesteak i have
what you went to angelo's and when i
tell you dog oh my you've been there
oh angelo you haven't been angelos where
in philly
you wear suplex
so they run that block when they were
looting i go hey man check in you guys
because they're blocked
are you guys alright he goes i think
we're good they sent me pictures they're
both
all their staff up front with guns yeah
because they're they're they don't want
their store to get
there it is i can't stop thinking about
this uh philly philly cheese
now hold on now that now this is your
boy's bradley cooper's favorite
restaurant
when he's filming silverline playbook he
lived in the upstairs so he could eat
the [ __ ]
food yeah that's what's upstairs the
best
provolone and that those italians
they'll put
on they'll put broccoli rob they'll put
peppers on that and forget it they make
the bread
there they make everything they make
everything right there steak broccoli
rob right there that's my oh my gosh and
i had a buffalo chicken one that was
stuck
did you have the you have the white
pizza too do you have their white pizza
oh yeah that white pizza that white pie
oh my god look at that italian look at
that semolina italian semolina roll
right there with that
those those sesame seeds now did you did
you go did you go to the
regular spots the regular cheesecake
spots no i didn't i didn't do any of
those those
they were they they said don't go
they're like let us take you
yeah to where we need to take you and
then they took me to that spot and it
was my boys
by the way philly is an amazing city
you've never been there
no that was my first time that's far as
far east as i've i've been that was
helium helium yeah june how you are yeah
how was it dude
electric i can't get over that yeah yeah
i did pretty good
not i'm not you guys yet but for helium
when they pack that room it's beautiful
oh my god
one of the best this is insane ceilings
i love it yeah low ceilings that's
perfect perfect stage perfect
set up perfect everything live the staff
was great did you like it on tv live yes
i told you how far is it from desert
ridge so here's the thing about arizona
you do temperatures by where the airbnb
doesn't compete with phoenix live i mean
stand up live
you do stand up live it doesn't compete
with desert ridge arizona maybe it's the
heat
they stay in their area that's kind of
like la though
yeah a little bit like this because
think about you like if you do pasadena
it doesn't conflict with that yeah
that's true if you do san diego it
doesn't [ __ ] with orange county right
yeah you do san diego irvine yeah you're
right yeah but arizona is yeah arizona
is like that we're
just 40 minutes away everywhere you go
saying daddy would like to go back to
arizona
listen cb live very impressive fun yeah
full capacity uh 220 220 so
how much how many dudes i think that's
only what it fits it can't be no
a little more but it was look every time
i did it it was completely full so yeah
i thought it only fit like one it's so
crazy to me these clubs have to do this
like even kentucky was like 70 capacity
what are we doing i turn on tv canelo's
fight in front of 73
000 how about that it is weird how about
it what drive me
i'm on the plane on the way here i gotta
they land on the uh you know when you
have to take the shuttle which already i
wanna die
are you an american yeah i wanna die i
don't fly america for that reason so
so now i so they we're we're packed in
this little it's a regional chat so
you're all packed i can touch the guy in
front of me
and then la so arizona's like come on
get on
we get to la i got to get on a shuttle
14 people per shuttle so
we're we're waiting but then you all
flew together 50 people
sitting next to each other
no sense it just makes zero sense and
it's [ __ ] crazy and
i i i can't do it it's so strange man i
mean but
philly they were all pretty much out
there like i mean i i think they're just
i guess uh they do have strict laws but
i mean they're pretty much like
doing that even new york could be the
it's like that's their
americans are figuring it out yeah
they're sick of it with americans
everybody's wearing the mask down
they're like after a while they're just
like what and everybody doesn't you know
yeah you can only enforce a law that
makes little sense
for so long for sure people just plus
we've lost our
trust in the government and government
officials it's like they don't know what
the [ __ ] they do
i mean then voucher came out i was like
i think people you know we even when
they say we don't have to wear masks i
still think there's gonna be a high
percentage wearing masks during flu
season oh he what
and i'm like you see him with his mask
down the camera
she's like this i'm like oh really i'm
like ah
yeah oh he's i don't know much about
yeah you just paid a lot but it's a no
it's annoying though oh the worst i
stopped
because like i think if out out here
they were like we got to wear them
i stopped that outside not anymore they
got rid of that does that stop wearing
it along they say if you're a vaccine
you have to wear it outside so
everyone's like oh we basically do what
we've been doing
yeah and then also all that does is
allow those you know those people that
got power from being like pull up your
mask yeah yeah their power's gone i know
arizona's lit lit though huh oh yeah
arizona's open they don't give him
it's like that's where we caught kobe
does yeah that's it that's right no no
no
i don't think so do you think no i think
texas
because i i felt sick on sunday okay and
i talked to a doctor
again no one knows what the [ __ ] is
going on but he goes
there's no week on san antonio because
you wouldn't get it on let's say friday
yeah and show symptoms but i showed
symptoms on like that wednesday
yeah so it took it it took so maybe i
got in arizona you've gone
maybe because because in san antonio on
the way to the show 400 people in the
room
it said uh we got an amber alert that
cove in 19 this was a hot spot
look at our green room 400 people and
more
so either there or arizona yeah because
i didn't go to san antonio with you guys
i was i just
but the day we left arizona i felt so
sick
but i just thought i was dehydrated
interesting did you feel sick when you
left arizona
probably i i got i had very little
energy because you get dehydrated and
you don't know it yep so i feel like
there's no strength
i'm just like what's wrong with me yeah
but since i was there it's so hot
are you like in arizona though people
have pride in their states if this is
more annoying like i'm like it's 100
degrees i'm like
i'm like oh you know i thought i was in
hell god i'm sorry you know
like it hit me in the back of the neck i
was like i went like that when i walked
outside
and i was like i might go for a hike and
the woman goes no you're not you go for
a hike
you'll die and dry up and whisper we got
to get a helicopter i'm like
it's one of the reasons then you go like
this to anybody from arizona you go so
hot and they go
wait a month dude
it's gonna get hotter but no june is our
hardest month that gets that 120. we
start around father's day and stuff
bro and i i listen arizona 120 is
different than la but where i'm at in
the valley we will get to 122.
oh you will oh yeah oh yeah last year
was it was the hottest day ever recorded
in l.a
really 122. it was so hot i wonder what
but also you know what you do you stay
inside in the ac
who gives you that's what and go to
you're going to your point that's why
people in arizona just pretty much like
if you live in this area you pretty much
do people in arizona because before that
we're trying to schedule those thick boy
bike club rides in like arizona
all boise all over yeah that's right
they were like oh you can do it but not
during the day we ride at night or
like five in the morning too yeah and i
was like oh then we're not doing it
because i'm not riding that night
because i have shows then i'm not waking
up at four to hit the trail
yeah that's that's pretty much like
you're like if you want to do something
outdoorsy
like that's your times yeah midday
or like any of that you just don't want
to did you did you uh did the fight
surprise you any anything surprising
this weekend no
canelo i mean billy billy joe
did salt you know he did good really
well yeah he's stunned yeah but i mean
does he be caleb oh yeah same way
there's no one can beat him he's like
chef chanko of the women's division
there's nothing for them
it's just like who's gonna get [ __ ] up
next jesus that's all we're watching
though
so good and hits so hard so good
i mean saunders did a great job so
honestly saunders is a [ __ ]
beast he's got that uppercut in his eye
his face didn't break
yeah no he's a stuff and was saying no
to his trainer when they were like we're
gonna stop the fight
because he's a warrior and then i i
wasn't there i'm at the
commentators who were saying he quit and
i was like you gotta have more
that's the zone though that's [ __ ]
that's the zone like have more respect
yeah i know
that's the zone though they're not gonna
be around much it was from an uppercut
yeah dude it was so hard
oh i mean through a glove just broke his
[ __ ] eye
oh such a stun did you what
are you so you you weren't at an airbnb
you were in uh i was at a hotel
hotel i like i don't like hotels oh hey
my airbnb i sent you that video
i'm like man what's this place so cheap
this place is great dude on the hour
on the hour every hour through the
entire night
the whole in the house the backyard's
the train track okay so that's right
now
[Music]
i'd wake up every hour dude i was
laughing and then and then jay
i posted and then jay would [ __ ] uh
no no chin it's down there down uh
where was me in bed he just went and
then jay sleeps like a [ __ ] wild boar
so he you know
so what
[Music]
that is so loud every hour on the hour
throughout the entire night
that's crazy did you get your money back
no i i i told james complain or anything
well because
you know jay books out runs it he's too
nice i'm like dude you have got to tell
them
hey [ __ ] faces on the description say
yeah the backyard is a train you have to
the but there's gonna be trains in the
backyard
but the bar there's like up this little
street and so up the street was a bar
and uh everyone's like oh you're staying
over there by the train track we saw
your video i'm like yep i told everybody
where i stay now
whatever they go at the bar every time a
train goes by it's free shots
i'm like oh they must be hammered
hammered
because it's everything they can drink
because i i had i got an airbnb and left
after the first night
why bad well when i when i get an airbnb
i get the whole place you get the whole
house
that works what it says you get the
whole house oh no you rented a room
did not i or i ran into no papa went
cheap no papa went cheap
there's the shared room oh no oh no i
got the whole house i'm very careful of
that
the problem was um i'm
in the kitchen and i hear an alarm like
my phone
go off and i'm like where the [ __ ] is my
phone where is
and i'm like i can't find it i look at
my phone that's not my alarm
i hear some guy what's up bro
well the host lives in the garage
she turned the garage in with one
bedroom and the door
they shared everything and they watch
you yeah and then i'm in the back with
my underwear and
comes out in the backyard like she's
like oh i'm just gonna blow i'm like no
i can't
just go to what you're right there yeah
you can't yeah that's not fair and they
don't tell you that now now
will i get my money back definitely no
what that happened
there's a big house right like eight
bedroom then there was this like
gas house in the back i'm like oh
someone can stand here i'll stand there
get away from the dudes so i go in the
doors like i'm like what the [ __ ]
i look in it's just a family of five i
was like oh
oh this is no this is your house
and then also they had pictures of their
kids all over the wall
and i'm like hey man and i said to the
woman i said
you know i this is a little strange for
me really she goes oh i can be elsewhere
now i'm like no i'm not just feeling
quiet now i don't want to kick her out i
just have to get out of there no you
would like
you so you didn't take a refund no my
girlfriend you got to get your money
back i don't i just can't
but when we were uh driving down the
street in kentucky i see this
bigger old dude like dude i'm trying to
make fun
like it would have took he was moving at
a snail space
it would have took him seven years to
get home and i made some joke and justin
j are laughing
and they were staring i'm like oh no i
think something's wrong with them and i
see him like go like this bigger like
big dude
yeah and then boom fall in his arms like
this and he's shaking
and i go oh [ __ ] he's probably having a
stroke yeah so we go around
the corner come back and i go you're
right man his elbow's all bloody
and he's like oh yeah i'm okay he's and
i go
uh do you know what happened he's like i
just fell over
and i go what's not you don't look good
man you need some help and he goes well
i live
you know like a mile up the road i'm
just walking i always walk every morning
because i haven't failed before and i go
uh but something's going on man goes oh
i had a stroke six months ago and i
paralyzed
the right side of my body so i'm just
trying to get out he went to walgreens
so i'm like okay he's like just help me
up my walk back i'm like dude you're not
walking back
and like you don't remember falling he's
like no i'm like dude how about i give
you a ride
yeah and so i go he can't get up like
literally can't get up because his body
won't work
so i help him up shirt ruined just blood
blood all the time
he's getting up like this
elbow
yeah okay and so we get them up and then
i go man i get to be honest i think we
should uh
call the cops i think we should call the
ambulance man so he can get checked out
because this isn't normal
and he's he's from london he goes do not
do that don't do that
do not nobody call the cops yeah i'm a
criminal and i'm like oh okay
yeah i thought that was a lot i'm like
okay and so i'm trying him up and then a
doctor who lives around the area pulls
up and goes
hey is he okay i go and he goes yes and
i look at the doc like this and goes
what happened he was
walking fun he goes i see him all the
time this is his route and i go
yeah i get that to his route but i'm
telling you he was obese he's
big big he's not doing well man he was
i'll be fine
just leave him like what the [ __ ]
wrong with people so i go dude i'm gonna
give you a ride back to your house so
justin's like damn man i go dude just
scoot over we'll put him in like
he can't really move he's like this like
yeah it's like this but as we're doing
that
some someone else drive a bike called
the cops so then i hear
sirens like a [ __ ] ambulance
fired and we're supposed to go to lunch
everyone's starving i thought it'd be a
quick ordeal you know help him up keep
going
well no brendan two hours later because
cops blocked us in
ambulance shut down the street [ __ ]
fire ban
fire i'm like oh this is the whole scene
and then the guy looks at me while i'm
helping out goes
thanks man but i can tell he's not
genuine he's like thanks man i don't
wanna make a big deal this i'm gonna be
here all day i went
oh oh i thought i was here to save this
life
but though so then the damage comes and
he and he refuses their help yeah
and the cop goes this happens man he's
alarmed by the
you know by all this and then i go all
right well we give him a ride he goes
we'll follow you just in case i'm
talking to cops all the cops came to the
show right they all come to the show but
i go drop them off and i go you know
something be like hey thanks a lot man
he goes
all right yeah he tells you to annoy
because all the cops and ambus came
and he goes hey did you by any chance
find my um apple
earbud i go no where would i find out
about you guys
i dropped it back do you mind going back
there looking for it for me i want to be
like
hey bubba hey dude my entire day
has been [ __ ] ruined now man i'm not
going to be
looking at
and now you're picking through the grass
because you have to look you kind of
looked no i was like uh
i guess man jay goes man [ __ ] this and
then the cop goes dude we'll handle it
you've done enough
so the cops went back and looked and
then when the cops came to the show that
night
they're like we never found it dude he
lost his [ __ ] earbuds yeah i saw a
guy
that's scary though i saw a huge guy die
right on that you know in the big quad
american he just was walking and he had
a sub
sandwich i never forgot he had a big
stench and he was probably
45 maybe 50 and just [ __ ] bob same
thing in new york
fellow in washington dc fell over on his
back
dead and i i'm just going you didn't try
to do anything
usually i would try but somebody jumped
on him right away
and started helping him then another
person started helping him and then the
guy started trying to do
[ __ ] i remember just seeing him dead
with that with that giant
sub sandwich there and i i i remember
going
i'm not going to eat subs anymore like i
saw the balloon
maybe that's a bad idea i don't know as
we're pulling up jake goes what the [ __ ]
are you gonna do
i don't know do something and then i
gotta help him and then i go i know ctr
so when you say stuff like that yeah now
did i take class for cpr yeah i did
was it 15 years ago yeah it was do i
kind of know what i'm doing
yeah yeah but doing cpr you can't kind
of figure it out you kind of gotta know
you know what the news it changes it
changes up all the time but do you know
what the new thing was
i know the basics so so so so tell me
how you would do cpr
uh well for you listen for a breath
first
and then um you would i think it's it
you blow and you cover their nose and
blow them to their mouth
and then you do the pumps so now they
say don't blow in the mouth anymore
now all you do is you just keep the
pressure yeah you get one
now here's the now here's the problem
daddy here's the problem now when you're
doing this on the sternum are you doing
the sternum right
yeah remember you're breaking ribs you
couldn't and your boys think it could be
yeah they do it all the time you know
now they have a machine that does it
but humans don't do anymore wow they
have a machine that they just put over
your chest and it goes
really sick yeah yeah they see that yeah
that keeps your heart pumping you want
to keep blood flowing because now
apparently the oxygen oh what's your
blood i had to take it uh when i worked
at the daycare
yeah that's the machine right there it's
like 12 grand now here's the problem
when i did cp
cpr class not those chin those are sad
obviously not those though huh
see that one see that i clicked on it it
takes you somewhere else
that's like that that thing for your
muscles but you just hit it and it goes
to work
how legit is that damn now would that
guy fit in that no
so we'll figure it out yeah but the
thing is is when i was getting
expands uh yeah you think or you just
like you got to get it under him though
you see that you're not getting them no
you need all the power
i bet i bet you can move it out i'm not
carrying that around that's that
like quick the machine get the machine
no but here's the thing when i was doing
cpr class
so they teach you you know the the mouth
and the chest but then they teach you
the heimlich
and so i didn't know anybody everybody
pairs up and then they're like oh
you're going to pair up with sarah i'm
like where the [ __ ] sarah well sarah was
about
400 pounds that's tough and they're like
oh oh
go ahead and get behind they're like oh
this and the teacher goes this would be
good because you're a bigger guy
dude i'm telling you i would i like i
was like yeah
[ __ ] yeah i'm it was it like yo dude
if you girl if you if you get a piece of
steak down your throat it's
it's gonna be it's time to go somebody
doesn't have a 82 inch reach no it's
getting yeah
unless dwight howard walks in right now
and because i can't i'm telling you i
was my fingers
that's crazy yeah that's yeah because
that's [ __ ] anthony davis is giving
you a heimlich i can't i saved a woman's
life
and a dog's life that way my own dog's
life but i saved a woman's life in a
restaurant
while on a date and and she was an older
woman
got behind her she was choking she did
the same she went and her friend who's
actually a famous actress olympia
dukakis goes
cat cat are you okay and i i go is she
choking but i'd save my dog like six
months before this way
she choked and she goes i jump over the
the the
i'm on a date i jump over the thing i
get in there bop
bop and she went yeah like that and i
saved what was it
any restaurant gave me here what was it
i'll give you did they comp your meal
they didn't call my meal unreal and it
was at ilbuco which is one of my
favorite restaurants
italian restaurant right one of the best
restaurants period and it was
god this was so long ago and they did
and i was talking to my girl this girl
who i ended up dating and living with
but
she said what would you have done if you
were on the airplane the hijacker you
know that and i said
i said i would never say i would never
say what i do because i have no idea
what i do with an emergency
i want to sit there no i hope especially
now knowing how it ends
right then that happens and i i remember
it was olympia dukakis because my
girlfriend at the time she was like
that's my favorite actress
i bet you she jumped your bones dude she
called her sister and goes i i'm i'm
marrying this i'm marrying this man i
married this is captain i couldn't
believe that i was
she and then olympia dukakis goes like
this she goes she's just some old
actress we don't yeah
she she won an oscar for moonstruck it
doesn't matter it's my generation she's
1960 oh okay
and she goes she looks at me and she
goes right
but she looks at me and she goes i know
see you're new
you're new to brian's stories i just i
was thinking nope so
like yep i'm not sticking with you when
it says dude
they were all older back then yeah she
looked at me you know she's the best the
best comment i've ever had in my life
she looked at me she goes
you were like a cat the way you jumped
over the
over this table you were a cat and she
went like this
and hugs me did you got no problem
sweetie then went back to you i got
embarrassed actually
caesar salad i got a little embarrassed
i didn't want to make it but everybody
in the restaurant like that and then
i laugh now hey i remember i remember i
was choking on uh
some nachos from taco bell you remember
just the nacho cheese and the simple
nachos
as a kid my dad i would get that and
churros the little churro sticks
and i had that and i was eating it and i
was just starving i was eating too fast
and the chip got stuck in my throat
and so it's me jay and my dad and we're
sitting there in the booth
and i'm just like my dad goes bren
you know and he's like bren and i'm like
brent i was like
nine or ten he was bren and then my face
started turned blue and i'm like
you know i'm going like this and my dad
goes he's choking and you know everybody
it's taco bell they're like all right
whatever man and so my dad like
like he didn't know the heimlich so he
took his his [ __ ]
dad big daddy dick beater that big dick
beater of a hand
with his [ __ ] oh he's missing yeah
he's missing this isn't it
he's listening to this i was wondering
why you were doing this he's down two
knocks he's down too
he's down two knuckles he took that
[ __ ] hand
and just wow
dude i was like oh whoa now i have ct
for sure papa whiplash it worked though
yeah where did he
you know in the back he'd be square in
the back as hard as he can damn it and
it worked
my friend my friend told the story about
how he
he and this girl decided this is [ __ ]
he and a girl decided to do it like they
decided we're going to make this work
and she they had this long-distance
relationship they broke up
and there was tears and then he called
her and they had this come to jesus
moment they said let's
do this let's give this a shot give this
a shot like a love story and
she she uh was late to her flight
she made a meal she ate and she died
and died at the [ __ ] kitchen table
alone in her house no heartbreak man
yeah what is he
to a group of us and he said the point
is take your time in life
i don't like the story man i don't like
the stories
i bet your friend was so fired up he's
like we're really doing this yeah
here's the shot she's like cool let me
just make this roast beef sandwich i'll
be right there yeah how about my other
buddy my other buddy's dying of
pancreatic cancer right
and and and the the there's a terrible
story where his
buddy his childhood friend his son and
he are in the water in acapulco
yeah and a boat's coming and this guy
has his son and he throws his son
his little son out of the way and the
boat kills him right
and it was but he did this heroic thing
and saved his son yeah
terrible story but my friend's dying of
pancreatic cancer and
in the obituary they write
like you know it was such an honor to he
loved he loved sam
and he like he mentioned how much he
loved his friend
meaning his he was it was like a tribute
to also the fact that
in that kind of you know oh yeah he's
not going to yeah
my buddy but we did a podcast about it
my biggest do you know how you know how
that feels when you're mentioning in
your friends oh [ __ ] you're like you're
going to
so obviously see like baby
how about me when your friends dying
like that i was like you're gonna beat
this dude
oh that's what we do [ __ ] it is
well one thing i do here uh you know
your restaurants that's what brendan was
telling me
yeah he said he made me he knows you
know we're on a road really good we're
on the road and
i'm like nope nope yeah yeah that's
because of him now yeah
you know them all you know but you once
you learn the difference it's like
anything else in life
that most people do this they go ah
that's just like that it's very easy to
say that's just like that yeah what's
difficult is understanding the
difference it's called
cultivating your your senses your taste
your ideas right like it's important to
know the difference between things
because like we'll go in a restaurant
until
and we won't know the restaurant like he
has a lot of stars and yelp and brian
i'll see brian like this look at the
kitchen and go let's get out of here
yeah you can just like literally
he's like that kitchen's not right i can
see her i'd see the little details
because details make all the difference
so if i see that the bread is shitty
or i see the baskets that they're doing
or i see nobody's taking time
but if i see if i see somebody took the
time with chalk
to you know and there are all these
little details
somebody cares it's more than just the
food if you care enough about those
little details you care about the food
there are little things yeah you see and
you go okay
was he near jt wings is that where is
that club out by there
uh jt's is a
he's a little bit of a stretch from jt's
best chicken wings ever happened
would you like chicken wings do you like
i don't know what do you like to eat if
it's good i'll do that but if these are
the best details like if somebody if
they haven't if they have lemonade in a
coffee shop
and they're taking mint sprigs yeah and
breaking them off and putting in there
everything's good yeah speaking of jt's
uh my friend
her her friend is the uh i think owner
or boss or something like that of jt's
and they want to send us some oh [ __ ]
yeah that's nice yeah that'd be nice
to keep i could use it for the fights
this weekend yeah
are they can they overnight it right
yeah i don't know how you want to
overnight
did they just overnight the socks yeah
well yeah you can like gold belly
they do that all the time it's gold
belly gold belly is that website where
you can order food from across the
country they'll ship it over to you
overnight no
yeah you can i know you can do that i
did that before stevie's birthday
you overnight key lime so well they
probably send the wings you know
that way they can send it frozen i'll
try it right right
i just filled them up and stuff like
that it's got to come out of the oven
got to come out of the oven i think so
man now i'm getting hungry too
damn gold you can do it from all the way
we'll tell you something philly like i
think yeah they have great
food in general yeah that's what i just
said that's well-known it's well-known
is it yeah i said i've never been there
you better chill i know that's what i'm
telling you though oh this is great food
yeah
feel like i don't need i'm trying it's
[ __ ] up i watch that dumb that
documentary not dumb
see spiricy on netflix oh yeah i watched
it too
what did you now now i'm not what is
your thoughts on it i heard they were
being a [ __ ] you know what the exxon
valdez that spilled that oil spill
three months yeah yeah yeah that that in
three months that didn't kill as many
fish or wildlife as
one day of fishing 4.6 million fishing
boats out there
you know when they say dolphin safe tuna
you know you know yeah that means
zero that just means the captain
nobody's out there chemicals yeah
there's no regulations yeah what okay
obviously seals
thousands of sharks thousands of
porpoises killed every day
all the time because we've become so
efficient at catching maybe
that's cool i'm glad you watched that
documentary how long do you think you're
not gonna eat fish i'll give it three
days
before you go to let's show you that new
york restaurant that brazilian where the
[ __ ] call
you know yeah i know you know what i got
the fish already dad
it's already dead i didn't do it that's
like ben franklin
ben franklin was a vegetarian and he's
on a boat on his way to england
and and he's like they're cooking cod
and with butter and he's like jesus
[ __ ] christ i gotta i'll take another
one of those biscuits i guess and get
scurvys like [ __ ] it's
so good he's like he's freaking out he's
like that looks so good
and then he sees they open one of the
fish and a bunch of other fish fall out
of it
and he goes hold on those fish are
eating fit
that's what they do if i eat a fish i'm
saving food yes and he goes
i'll have cod if i eat fish i'm saving
fish
so you're not going to stop eating fish
it's going to last it's going to be
three days
it might be three weeks i just don't
think it's good that they catch me no
it's a bummer you watch
that [ __ ] sharks so yeah so they're
killing seals and dolphins just to get
to the fish there are areas there are
areas and they tre and the trawlers that
drag the bottom of the ocean
there are areas in the atlantic in the
pacific that are as barren as a desert
and they cover the size of western
europe
it's crazy you know big ocean is so
popular it's big but it's getting to a
pool yeah it's getting bad
where we are literally at a point where
well they said they they don't know why
they say
ahi tuna is really [ __ ] yeah because
the japanese are jealous oh forget it
but you know why
it's all in china usually it's
especially toro now it's also the
chinese but you know you know uh it's
also run by criminal gangs now but you
know you know what
all the criminals the the do you know
why like one blue fin tuna can cost
twenty thousand thirty thousand forty
thousand yeah at least
when you know all the coral that's dying
it's not global warming they think it's
because the fish are being killed
because when the fish eat
they excrete stuff and the coral eats
that oh wow but when you kill all the
fish all the coral dies
it's getting bit bit bad so i got to
watch this
or not yeah what you know i want to
make you sad and also don't i'm sure but
also don't me wrong i'm sure it's
terrible
remember any of these documentaries have
an agenda all of them have an agenda
also i don't
i don't even fish heavy or yeah fish
at all really yeah i don't know i mean
but i do i'm sure it's bad but they all
haven't
overfishing has been a big problem for
sure
so the the doc i watched this weekend
was uh the
son of sons of sam oh i saw that on
netflix you watched it no i didn't watch
it oh it's good you know son of sam the
new york
serial killer it goes into how [ __ ] the
new york police department did that
because you know
it's called sons of sam's because they
figured out now over time and with
technology there was way more sons of
sams there was a whole group
he it just wasn't david berkowitz
killing everybody he had a whole team
it was like these uh which like satan
worship is that true though that's true
yeah and one one one guy commits suicide
the other one actually is serving time
because there's multiple killers because
they're trying to figure it out because
you know they caught him someone
snitched on him they caught him
and the new york police department
because new york was so scared
they just want to be like yep it's done
with you don't be scared anymore
and but the other detectives and
reporters were like this doesn't make
sense they put it all on him
they put it all on him but then the
reporters follow it like but the
sketches
like they're saying like i get he kept
saying he's wearing wigs and stuff
because
one person's like hey it's curly here
yeah it's straight here yeah
it's this here yeah he's a shaved head
and they're like oh it's just
uh david berkowitz wearing different
wigs but then when they would talk to
people who would actually see the
shooters in new york it didn't match up
with him and then they figured out he's
part of this cult
he was a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
psychopath just like what was the
yeah just like he would shoot people
right you should be but
son of sam so the there's actually a son
of sam this guy sam
yeah who would beat his son and him and
that son they found out was one of the
main ones doing
a lot of the killing and his he was
actually the son of this guy named
is he still alive he's not alive no in
the son of sam guy
because whoever like would snitch on the
group
and who was going to give it away they
would take out so
people from the group moved or just left
because they found out that this group
would
kill him off so the son of sam left i
think he was in arizona or some [ __ ]
like that
and he found out they're coming after
him and they said if you don't kill
yourself we're gonna kill your family
your kids and your wife
so he just took his own life which once
was the actual son of
david no no he's not the real son of sam
there's a real son of the guy who's the
actual
born son of this guy sam son of sam's is
a group
damn yeah that's weird it's fascinating
it even connects to
it it even connects uh charles manson
and and he died
how did this [ __ ] uh the son of sam's
connect with charles mentioned because
they're all going off this one book
this guy where they started in england
they they're all learning off that
so is he dead it doesn't sound [ __ ]
crazy is he dead or no no
he's just born 67 years old yeah
still doing the damn thing in new york
then but he stopped communicating with
the police
because he he goes if i keep talking to
you they're going to kill my dad
and he's like i'm already here i'm
[ __ ] so he was italian
it says yeah name falco
why would he burka was maybe he took his
mother's name or something
now that guy looks like his dad next to
him yeah
you know he's still alive killing
somebody
like he was a picture of him [ __ ]
crazy he's just crazy
updated picture yeah the whole the whole
thing was they're all weird did he kill
him remember a violent
satanic cult who did he kill anyway did
he kill just different was it specific
kind of person like women
men uh like uh he they killed a number
of women they killed number of couples
too
just random [ __ ] oh that's what he looks
like now yeah it looks like [ __ ]
[ __ ] it was uh random there was no
intent behind it there was already the
only intent there was there was
uh one girl who was uh
a member of uh the like a catholic
church
and somehow she you know she would try
and convert people to
uh be catholic and she stumbled upon
this group
and was trying to convert some of the
group members to be catholic and saying
how bad what they're doing
and they she's the only one they sought
out and i forget where it was at
in a church it was in stanford in a
church she was in a church
and they uh they murder in the church
like horrible killing in the church this
was at stanford
they found with like she was like all
right whatever laughed went to school at
stanford
they followed her from idaho because
that they're they were based out of
idaho the sons of samsara this
cult was they followed her when she got
to stanford and murdered her
in this church damn [ __ ] well i watched
the last stance doc
that's been out for i know three years
dawg no michael jordan could play some
ball
yeah it was fascinating it's good man
that was all about it you haven't you
know any of that huh no
i didn't know any of that how
competitive was jordan oh my god
i i loved that that was the nba no i
know oh it's such a different thing even
jordan was such a different guy
getting knocked to the ground beating
yeah like straight up like hard fouls
there's nothing that may be so soft
there's no one like that nba no there's
no one there's no like why do they make
it that way just because
points protect their protect their
assets yeah that's why that's why the
they're such high scoring like people
are getting like one the defense
they don't want to foul you can't play
hardball anymore yeah there's no
bruisers there's no like
what i loved about him is that anytime
anyone like
said anything about him or he felt like
disrespected by them oh he
next game he'd be like all right he was
super petty all right bit but there's
also there was a thing going around the
league where
uh there's a new rookie i forget what
team he was on there's just a
jet i don't think this was on this i
don't think it was in this dock
someone was telling the story about
jordan i think it was jaylen rose
but there was this young rookie came in
the league
and uh this other guy was guarding
jordan and this young ricky kept talking
[ __ ] to jordan
and i think it was isaiah ryder so it's
for the trailblazers look dormant
dude you don't have to guard him don't
don't fire him up man
be cool because jordan was having like a
slow game he had like 12 points in the
first half i'm mad
yeah he had 12 points in the first
second quarter and he wasn't like do
he's just coasting
and then that young buck started talking
[ __ ] to him and uh isaiah
ryder was like dude you don't have to
guard him i do everybody knows don't
talk [ __ ] to jordan
yeah that's the unspoken rule dude this
kid kept talking [ __ ] to him
he scored like 50 points the second half
oh yeah
i don't think they talked and then
looked at the kid and was like and i
guess he walked back he was like now
you'll learn to shut the [ __ ] up
everyone's like jesus he he yeah
you knew not to fire him but i i love
that though i love that about him that
it was just like
they said if social media was back was
around when he was around he
we wouldn't look at him the same because
he was notorious [ __ ] my buddy my
buddy
is his caddie and my buddy said like if
you put money down
he always delivers and my buddy played
on the tour you know so he has to
spot some points but he said what uh and
i've had i've heard a number of
professional golfers real golfers said
his short game
is as good as anybody on the tourist
it's his long game you know
golf is a thing you know but he said and
he said how do you how do you always do
that without choking and he goes
fundamentals i just go back to the
fundamentals she's a beast
hey kids if you're out there you got a
fam you're stressed you need
food man you need good food but you
don't feel like cooking all right i got
you covered you gotta get with grubhub
they have all the food that you love
from your favorite local restaurants all
right
they got you covered take a break from
cooking all right take a break from
cooking order the food you love from
your favorite restaurants with grubhub
all right or you can pick it up try
something new we got you covered man
family friendly there's a variety of
choices so you can provide for the
family
get the food you love with the perks
from grubhub grub what you
love no no no no seguro said that sugar
sugar was on wrote he's
telling this jordan story where he'll
play uh like so
the three of us are playing jordan will
he he will only bet he won't just play
to play yeah
there's always money online yeah so
he'll know how much money you make
so he'll go whatever you're making a
million dollars a year he says i'll bet
you a hundred thousand
you're making five million a year i'll
bet you're two hundred thousand so he
based bet of what your income
is and then yeah sugar was saying he
beat this guy
it was like 70 g's and it's not like
yeah give it to me when he can
he was like dude where's my money and
he's like i'll get two he's like no
i need it by tomorrow at 9 00 am dude
where the [ __ ] is my money
the guy's like jesus christ yeah he
wants that
[Laughter]
i don't think you become that insanely
good without being
a little bit off in that sense yeah his
work work ethic was insane like when he
was filming a space jam
he he uh he had other players in the
league come out
and so when he would be on a 12-hour day
of set
you know for space jam then they would
play like three hours of basketball
the who's who would be there yeah
alvarez is that way he's obsessed like
they say he's just
always in the gym oh really yeah it's
like
andy ruiz was training with those guys
and he goes i mean he lost 50 pounds
he's like
you know i'm i'm with these dudes a
whole different decision yeah
the only one close to jordan like
mindset would have been uh
kobe yeah kobe was really yeah but kobe
also like
said he joined he said i learned from
yeah from him yeah
he called jordan apparently oh yeah yeah
he said he would call him up yeah two in
the morning like hey man i'm thinking
about like
and then kobe be mean to you like if
like dwight howard and kobe didn't get
along because dwight thought he was lazy
sorry you're fired yeah
kobe like with dwight howard like he
wasn't playing well like he was in a rut
and then kobe would be at the gym at
like four in the morning and then dwight
would get that at the regular time like
seven he'd be like what are you doing
man
treat him like [ __ ] he'd bully him
basically he called up a complaint
jordan went hard on people too that's
right i'm in uh her in the face yeah he
said to his coaching i'm not playing
with
when jeremy lin was playing with him and
lynn he just felt like wasn't
showing up he goes i'm not getting on
the court with him i don't want to play
with him and then he called like
kobe kobe then he called like one of his
teammates
who i sat next on the plane and he was
like uh i don't want to play with him
man four in the morning he's like what
he was i don't i don't want him i don't
want him on the team he's here
just talking to him he would take
everything personally yeah but i mean do
you guys
do you guys think that's like mean or is
it they just have a different
competitive edge
i mean that's it if you're that good i'm
gonna listen yeah that's what i'm saying
like if you're that
but if you're just like if you're just
like
[ __ ] that that's what that's what i'm
saying like i don't like if bill paxton
was like i don't i don't want to play
with dennis rod man i don't like that
but maybe i shut the [ __ ] up but if it's
jordan or kobe or
once in a generation town i'm gonna
listen yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
yeah
some people were like winners made it
seem like i mean he was being mean or
whatever but it's like
he could back it up they're extreme
winners are like winning is everything
and losing is
the worst thing bill parcells was that
way apparently like his i think his
ex-wife was talking about it like
when he would lose it would be it would
like he felt like there was bile in his
in his throat like he couldn't like
literally physically he would get sick
some people are just i mean there's you
know so ultra competitive even
it sounds like exhausted me jordan's
friend like even if you got a girl over
him
he may not have friends like it depends
yeah yeah
he broke just kicks you with his kids i
don't know i don't know that
i don't know if you know that's your dad
yeah be exhausting oh like that dude
i don't have money to bet you right i've
lost my life yeah
man you pay me all yeah i'll say they
work for them right
kids work for the jordan break they do
oh yeah wow he does not know what else
are you gonna do
a guy like that though his family is
probably his you know like that's
part of the competition that's part of
like you know there's there's
there's us and then well but also you
can't
if you marry michael jordan have kids
with them you know that's like being
upset you by a pit bull and it's
aggressive like you you signed up you
made [ __ ] michael michael jordan he's
he's
his kids jaguar yeah he's not going to
be a pet like a dog
yeah his kid played at i think florida
atlantic fiu i think
florida oh that was when he just did
college he wasn't very good yeah oh
really
hmm yeah what are yeah what that's
michael jordan yeah i wonder how he
would be like
did he try to coach or anything like
that who jordan yeah he owned he owns
uh the bobcats i know that he doesn't he
doesn't all right he's
no he's too competitive yeah like
they're they're they they drafted kwame
brown
and he you know and jordan vouch for him
and then sawyer wasn't very good
i guess the guy said something to jordan
jordan was 50 at the time
and this was his first day and jordan
goes hey let's play one on one the kid's
like dude you don't want to do this
jordan's like yeah i do
he beat him so bad they said he like his
his confidence was
he he was a bust he never came back
because he destroyed him one-on-one
he was up in the office in his suit and
was like oh
this is the kid i vouched for dude let's
play one-on-one and beat him so bad that
the kid was like
get in your kitchen gets in your kitchen
because you always leave
one one window open in your house
everybody thinks they got all the
windows closed in their house you find
that one windows cover
like the night stalkers just a little
illusion yeah this little compromise and
he pop up and then
now he's in your kitchen and he's moving
[ __ ] around and you hear clanging
and now you can't do it they're very
that's what he does you can't
you your house ain't locked up to that
degree dude
that's an exact quote from the night
stalker that's right is it really yes
oh that's exactly what he no i'm telling
you that's exactly what he's talking
about nightstalker said the exact same
thing there's always
there's always a way i wish you wouldn't
quote me your house i wish you wouldn't
quote him right he's a bad person but
hey i thought his uh baseball career was
pretty interesting too
jordan's wouldn't never did an interview
with sports illustrated again after they
said his mic
oh yeah baseball yep and the baseball
player said nobody worked like him
nobody worked that hard
i mean yeah that's what was sam not
playing since high school and going
like he wasn't awful that's what they
were saying and here's the other thing
neither was tim tebow dude
also never played college was pretty
good yes and now you know t was going to
try out with the
with the jacksonville jaguars that tight
end you signed up tight end
they signed up they signed them they
signed real you know urban myers is the
coach and that him and timmy are
super close and they're also next door
neighbors oh
and timmy wants to play still mm-hmm huh
how old is he
he pretty younger yeah he's gonna be
older for
he has to be i think i'm two years older
than that would they would they
use him as a is there is there are there
he's thirty three so
he plays where he always walks back oh
yeah same age pretty much no don't ask
that question
okay you're tied in dropping back no but
no
you could use like a wildcat package or
something but he wouldn't play tied in
he'd go over to quarterback oh you could
do a shift where
the starting quarterback yeah or he does
the jump pad
he's a giant man so i would imagine he
catching balls for him i don't know what
his hands are like
great hands [ __ ] athletes
oh you want to talk about a savage like
mentally toughest [ __ ]
mentally can't
how much scrutiny he gets and [ __ ] he
gets speed
how old is he now 30 33
not terrible not terrible dude
is that like your average age it's not
like you know he's not like 36
like yeah he and probably two years left
two years especially at tight end
how old is gronk he's still playing
right tight end yeah gronk is
he's a gold holder really i'd say like
probably
36 there's no reason why he can't
tim really well i mean i'm fascinated to
see that will he start
i doubt it because there's a lot of
blocking too right just depends what you
are
yeah there's blocking tight ends there's
receiving tight ends there's times so he
must he must be working out a lot and
stuff
and just staying he always works out
dude right always
yeah he's a monster dude there's not
listen there's not a harder worker in
the room and you guys are friends with
him right
yeah that's my boy yeah he's a [ __ ]
great customer
great guy you did his charity show yeah
he's a great guy he bombed and you
killed it right
very good i had a really really good
yeah i didn't do well
um but i had an amazing talk with him
yeah he um
about religion and and sort of but he's
very very
articulate on that subject like he's
very grounded in his faith but he can
back it up
well think about everyone questions
since you've been a kid it really
questions his faith
so if you they thought it was like false
or something no it's just you know if
you're that balls demon
religion you know i do it to my uh
father-in-law all the time he grew up
super catholic
on easter i mean him got into it not a
bad way but if you're gonna
have that discussion yeah if you're
gonna question someone on the on their
face
you better have some legit points yeah
well yeah because because if you go with
the basic [ __ ]
it's like making fun of david foster for
being fat he's been fat his entire life
he roasts people for a living so if
you're who
uh dave david lucas oh i was like who's
david david so if you're gonna roast
david lucas you can't you have something
else
you gotta have something yeah so if
you're gonna question tim's face he's
hurting
he's he's heard it all and he's ready to
go yeah it's like a heckler like if you
heckle rogan or brian or
[ __ ] dane cook dude you you what you
think saying
you're not funny it's gonna work yeah
you don't think they've heard that
from day one growing up in boston yeah
so you better come up with something
original otherwise you can get
annihilated but it seems like i mean
just from
being an outsider it seems like he just
keeps his religion like pretty much like
it's his thing
he holds on to it it's not it's not like
it's like i don't know
he's not pushing it on anyone i wouldn't
say that's all
i want to say that jesus is really going
to speak something yeah i used to i used
what do you mean i used to go to bible
study he probably just casually invited
you though and probably wasn't like
you need to do that he didn't want to
disappoint him so brandon probably can
just see him going yeah
i showed up every wednesday i
i stopped going because i talked to the
pastor and i said uh
i said yeah i'm listening to you guys
talking about it was basically
networking all these famous people i was
like this doesn't feel right yeah
so and then and then i i said uh
so in the you were talking about today
because they always have like there's
always a theme every wednesday
and we do at the beverly hills hotel and
we got done i asked the pastor i said so
like my dad and brother don't believe in
god what happens to them because
hopefully they do man otherwise they're
going to hell i was like that can't be
right
they're great people they're nice people
so what happens to the people that don't
have the opportunity to learn about
catholic or christianity
see i believe the only thing i believe
if you don't believe in christ
you're going to have well if you hold a
match and hold your finger in it
and think of your whole body that way
for eternity but that's the only thing
i'm saying
just kidding oh chappelle thought you
were serious i know
ryan you did the real job no no you
didn't get the job
i'm not christian i listen to you so
much because you you speak so well
he's smartest i don't believe that you
burn no never don't sit in a lake of
fire if you don't take right
but are you not religious are you i i
have respect for religion and i can talk
to you for a long time about it but i
i i don't think it's it's very hard for
me to reconcile that i have to be
accept that christ was god and the
messiah
and that everybody else is wrong that's
why but yeah but i think christianity
is a pretty it's a it's a very
interesting religion
in in that love thy neighbor love thy
enemy there's some great things
like like the basic the basic principles
of religion
is no matter what religion well if you
if you get rid of
if you get rid of religion like which we
have done if you get rid of organized
religion
see human beings are religious they are
religious and they're going to get
religious about something like diet
politics wokeness yeah wokeness is
a religion it's about purity you purify
the ranks you excommunicate people that
are not with you you find out where they
are
you kick him out of the community that's
what social security social media
when whenever you are human beings are
when they're obsessed historically with
purity
when they're obsessed wahhabi islam
which is a form of islam that's obsessed
in a sense with purity purifying
anytime you hear anybody talking about
we can we got to get rid of these people
over here to make the society perfect
don't trust them
utopia do not trust them be very careful
of those yeah
those are the people you look out for
which is like there's kind of like a new
age of it
no any time you have an ideology which
is a sick religion
it's kind of just always been anytime
you believe you can perfect human beings
or society what you're going to do
historically at every turn is you're
going to go these people over here are
beyond redemption they're too old
they're too successful
their re-education won't work for them
yeah uh so let's we got it
we gotta get ready but that's the but
they've never they've never succeeded
well that's awesome you know that's
awesome that's
people talk about castro talk to gay
people talk to the people that were on
the margins with
in castro's regime talk to them that
there's
the council's examples of people like
you guys over here are just inconvenient
we got to move you out of the way
yeah we had 100 million graves to point
to with the communist revolutions 100
million
so but it seems like that mob just
pretty much takes
the online world if i'm correct
they're taking the online world but then
the the online world scares the big
corporations the corporations make
changes
and then that mob goes after disney now
disney has to change the [ __ ] snow
white
movie you know so that like it trickles
down it's not gonna change until
sensible people start boycotting
start saying i'm not buying from that
corporation well until the movers and
shakers yeah until the movers go hold up
this is insane we gotta stop that's
exhausting we can only get so well yeah
yeah otherwise because the prince kills
snow white to save her life
yeah oh they and they're saying well
there there's oh this is a real thing
oh yeah yeah no one's heard this no one
reads the news no
i did yeah yeah they're going after
cartoons they're going after they're
going after snow white saying she was
asleep didn't give the prince consent to
kiss her
so they need to get rid of that movie
and the ride at disneyland
wow and and people allow it to happen
wait who's allowing no one can just go
no one's no they don't have the guts
like people are just scared to say yo
[ __ ] you i i
don't know they should they shouldn't
really a new thing either because they
did something like this to
the pirates of the caribbean ride there
was a section where
uh women were being auctioned off and
they actually
changed it that's different no but i'm
just saying like like that makes sense
this is the woke left trying to change
everything trying to look for it in
everything yeah but there's like auction
off women like they're saying [ __ ] off
you know this is this is insane you can
argue that you would do that to beauty
uh sleeping beauty too because that
whole
like the origins of that in the grimm's
tale is that she was raped and woke up
because she gave birth
and they have sleep i mean we could go
back that old school if you want yeah
this
ride isn't that grim but this is great
they're saying that that that that
prince kissed her without her consent
and they need to get rid of that in grim
but that's not the story that disney
tells
grims if you read grimm's the original
uh cinderella
yeah it's not yeah they cut their own
toes out to fit in that slipper they're
like let's just lop off these digits or
uh uh what's what's the other one um
[ __ ] hands-on great yeah yeah i want
super stuffy she puts him in the kids in
the cage he's going to get them plump so
she can eat
kill them motto is don't trust strangers
yes but
okay but it's okay so the snow white
thing then what
what is that what does that mean what is
that nothing will make them happy
it does it won't stop there and so if so
if they start tailoring towards that
then it's going to go on to everything
so it seems like these corporations
think the online world is like the
reality yes and it's not
and it's it's it's the madness of crowds
douglas murray wrote a book called
massive crowds that's a great does a
great job of showing you how crazy this
is i'll read it and people have to stand
up to it
you have to see it but it's the only way
it's going to happen you got to draw the
line saying
whoa yes this we agree is bad but this
we
we they were they were crying
the publishers the the woke publishers
were crying about having to
publish his book there's nothing extreme
about jordan peterson
nothing and they were like crying and
they hadn't even read the book
this isn't you know you know who has
balls is spotify because
so many of the sport of spotify woke
workers and [ __ ]
new york are like you know the he's he's
you know he's anti
this rogan's anti this into this and
then he said the vaccination thing like
all right this is the final straw you
gotta kick him off
spotify said cool story hey our
company's gone up three billion dollars
since we signed them and the the
the downloads are the highest we've ever
had yeah money talks
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah so money
yeah but people
ordinary citizens have to be very
conscious when when a corporation does
[ __ ] like that and folds to the mob
to the mob the mindless mob but it's
starting to
look look at the nba look at the nba
when they were like oh we're protesting
that shooting
and and the the main [ __ ]
citizens of the us went hold up have you
seen this like this isn't a racist woman
was trying to stab
another woman well that one's different
that well yeah i agree with that one
this is the one where
remember that guy um he was trying to
take his kids and the
the wife the ex-wife called the cops and
he had a restraining order against them
and then the cops shot him like several
times probably didn't shoot him so much
but then they protest and didn't play
games well amer the america who watches
nba went that ain't right man
like what you're what what you're dying
on this hill for isn't right
so the numbers went good
so now the the nba has to suffer from
lebron james
or lebron james going that cop you're
you're next
all right well now his jersey sales and
everything's you know it's no one's
watching the games
is that is that what happened yeah he's
been out for 24 years huh
he's been out he's actually the sore
ankle or because oh yeah i'm sure sorry
oh yeah he got hurt again how
interesting that he did
everybody didn't get her backlash man on
that guy no he but he
he had so much backlash she came out
apologize i was like i didn't look into
it enough
but that's the problem yes there's the
smarter
yeah but if you're gonna do it and you
know nothing about it if you at least
look into it yeah
because you do narrate how people think
so by you doing that that makes matters
worse that divides us even more so that
guy was talking about people who are
like you know
for decriminalizing the border and i
just i had a border control agent come
to my show and and talking about
how insane it is showing me video of of
how
[ __ ] nuts that border is they're
letting everybody over if you're caught
smuggling people open
you don't get arrested you don't get
prosecuted when you are
caught over the border you're released
on your own recognizance
and then you have to come back for a
court date two years later yeah there's
they're
decriminalizing the world and this guy
was like all these people who are
fighting for immigrant rights coming
over they don't speak a word spanish
they don't speak a word of spanish they
don't know anything about that they
don't even
know they just it's just easy no one
knows the details yeah you don't live
there you don't you don't see what those
border controls so
yeah you're just saying it's easy you're
not paying to have those people come
over
and and deal with all that that stuff
yeah it's not doing that
it's not responsible so so you so i
guess borders don't mean anything
borders aren't reasonable
take the front door off your house how
about those people do that but you know
[ __ ] it no did you hear that the woke
left is trying to start uh
start only teaching the positive parts
of history in schools now they want to
get rid of like
all the the uh bad parts of history
because you can't
yeah i know you wouldn't have history i
i know like they were gonna
know that stuff i i don't know where i
read it but like i saw some school i
think it was like
some school in indiana or some weird
state that they were trying to
look they weren't teaching uh slavery
like they weren't teaching any of that
[ __ ] they wanted to
have a positive reinforcement about
how uh about us's history they can't do
it already yeah they think
yeah that might be a backlash to the
fact that they're trying
also to teach the idea that america was
only founded on slavery only founded on
bad things
and they don't look at the genius of
james madison alexander hamilton
and the genius of the political system
that they set up i doubt you they're
teaching that though what you're talking
about there's no way no they're not no
that's what i'm saying there's a there's
a there's
gonna tell you christopher columbus
discovered this he was the first one
which we know isn't true there's all
this [ __ ]
yeah they didn't teach any of that [ __ ]
in high school for me at least you know
history you go to public school history
has been pretty
uh private you went to private school
yeah private catholic school yeah damn
dog
oh damn don't calm down still don't know
the difference between christianity and
catholicism
honestly oh well we don't we don't want
to get in we don't want to get down here
because we don't want to lose all the
listeners because they're already bored
he was
i always kept it on a good track because
i'll go deep in this i was like did you
say judy oh yeah i heard this was going
to happen
so elon musk was on saturday night live
some people thought he bombed it really
just kind of depends on
listen he could have put on a jim carrey
performance and those people are still
going to say he bombed
yeah because they don't like him because
he's the richest man in the world um
but he went on and a lot of people were
upset about it because
dogecoin went from 70 cents to i believe
54 cents and so it's currently at
a dip and people are blaming elon musk
for being on saturday
saturday night live they know that they
know what's gonna happen though
i think because a bunch of people
thought it was gonna go in the other
direction was gonna hit a dollar and
then dip
people were kind of expecting that huge
spike and then
dump it all did he is he talking [ __ ]
about dogecoin or something no he's
absolutely for dogecoin but he said it
was a hustle right
uh yeah he said that he wouldn't advise
anybody
to invest an absurd amount of money into
it and that you should invest
responsibly
but he also said that dogecoin is the
future so
it's kind of like it's elon musk you
never know
damn well my buddy you know kevin bay
yeah
kevin said kevin said he goes he was in
he was
in dogecoin and he's like it's going to
dip it's going to dip sweat it was up 74
cents and he bought it like
10 cents i think he goes i'm gonna i'm
going to sell and then buy
so so elon musk does saturday night live
and he said to me he kept saying goes
as soon as he's on it's going to crash
so you got to sell right before
he said after my show on saturday late
show he goes
[ __ ] i forgot
he came out with 15 mil oh yeah oh he
got out
uh i don't know if he got out or he just
kept holding but you still know
well it's not 15 mil now but at the
price point you got it
he still has a bunch of millions of
dollars in it that's cool so it really
depends on when you got in how much
money you put into it you can make some
money
white mike's doing pretty good with it
really i might it's cool
yeah that sounds like a coin you'd be
into oh yeah what else you got
so a uh senator over in ohio state
was on a zoom call where they were
trying to debate about
what the rules of distracted driving
would be
and while he's on the zoom call he is
actually
in his car driving really and they
caught him they
he had like a weird background yeah his
background
but you can see his seat belt he's a
seat belt and this was actually live
stream to a government website
so he thought that no one was gonna see
it or capture
a backdrop that maybe that was his
office and he was in his car he must
have like placed his car onto some sort
of
contraption but you could see his
seatbelt trolling board you can see
republicans
when he stopped andrew brenner is
sitting in his car
parked but a couple of minutes later
i had some [ __ ] to do man all right i
had to pick up kids or some [ __ ]
[Applause]
it's so obvious throughout the rest of
the meeting you can see
senator brenner glancing around and
turning the steering wheel
a bit later he appears to be pressing a
button to
unmute himself preparing to speak
senator brenner
no holes and then he appears to salute
before the final sign off
but that wasn't where his short zooming
while driving journey
ended it's now making national news
he put that background up because he
didn't want you to know but he was just
listening
yeah was yeah so that was his argument
he was saying that he wasn't necessarily
driving distracted and being distracted
because he was
almost like a voice [ __ ] yeah yeah
i guess it's dangerous or something yeah
he was driving from one place to another
he said he said i was paying attention
to the driving and listening to it
yeah because it seems like he placed his
phone like on the
yeah like on a wall no though
obviously he said phone calls for the
most part but on video calls i'm not
paying attention to the video to me it's
like a phone call
that's fair yeah that's fair they need
to chill on homie man let him live his
life
i can't believe people qualify that it's
news nowadays
it's the news needs you've got to get
clicks man they you they need your
attention it's not about the truth
they're
they want your attention yeah anything
they can get okay so
brendan i know you love euphoria so do i
sydney sweeney
uh actually went on instagram live
crying because
she was at home hanging out with her dog
watching hgtv when she noticed that she
was trending on twitter randomly
and she didn't know why because she
didn't have anything to promote she
didn't do like some interview that was
going viral
it was actually somebody who posted a
photo of her
and made it just so it's her face and
right above her chest saying
uh she looks like a muppet and their
whole thing is
she's only hot if you see her body but
her face is ugly and
other people they're so pretty went on
and started to [ __ ] on her and so she
went on instagram live
basically crying saying like just so you
know this [ __ ] does hurt wait so
that was lit lee [ __ ] huh
at least i think it's lay like uh it's a
meme
oh ellie hit play chin
apparently i am trending on twitter
she's gorgeous
she's absolutely gorgeous stunning drop
dead that's such a shame
would never actually do this
i think it's really important for people
to see
how words actually affect people and i
know everyone says like you can't read
things
you shouldn't read things you're in once
upon a time in hollywood girl yeah she's
super pretty by the way
and somebody called her a muppet stop
stop
oh attention also like this is for
attention this is not you know you're
fine
on social media you're fine one person
called you a muppet she's young
get off like early 20s early 20s i mean
come on
but i mean you got to say at some point
you really have to say [ __ ] social media
mm-hmm
you really do well if you're going look
at it i mean
those people have those people literally
have nothing to do but they don't they
don't
oh a holy [ __ ] like yeah she's
like
you poor thing no one you cried because
you look like a muppet so we have to
stop everything i feel bad for you
i do kind of feel bad for her because
she got a lot of her fame
very very recently and it was almost
overnight okay but
i'm saying be your friend i just feel
like you're 59 years old
i mean like but right you're 58. 54.
okay
but for you you know you care about
social media for her like this
this young like she's young so like
social media is everything
sir sir when you look like that and
there are people out there that don't
look like that who have real
physical problems you can't you can't be
upset with somebody like i do what
you're saying because you're doing it
for attention and that's ridiculous you
don't think she has people you don't
think she has people in her corner
being like hey [ __ ] that [ __ ] there's
got to be someone in her
corner one person said you look like a
muppet and she's crying when she's like
that
get them meanwhile majority of the
comments she probably gets
are damn she's bad she's not going to
know you maybe
she's also i would pretty much online
sucks online does suck it's like [ __ ]
what people say online does it literally
doesn't matter because
most people aren't doing anything but
she's young though man i don't feel bad
that was the bad that people were
[ __ ] on her for she's still looking
she's still beautiful
what do you mean a muppet stop everybody
that's a muppet certainly
does it feel bad player hit me with
brian's priest yeah
yeah absolutely you got a prius one of
my cars
well easy daddy bought it for somebody
okay i bought it for a video
tesla i bought it for for daddy's
driving yeah
i think i'm driving my test this summer
yeah we gotta turn that in right
i think it depends on what fan base
you're a part of because some of these
fan bases for like the younger
generation is ruthless like
there is this girl named charlie demilio
she's the biggest tick-tocker
she will randomly trend on twitter
because it's like it happens to be her
birthday
she doesn't say anything and people then
have her trending on twitter saying like
[ __ ] you you should die
happy birthday brat and it's like she's
17. she's so young
chappelle she's that trust me is so
important how old is this girl
this girl i think she's 22 23 21 maybe
fairly young but social media
it's so healthy that's what i'm saying
like like like haven't we learned that
already
that social media is just [ __ ] up
mm-hmm yeah you know what i mean like
i mean it's so obvious it makes you
breaks you too though i mean she also
gets a lot of love on social media yeah
yeah but i mean but just a lot of
attention i feel like just as much as
you get that love you shouldn't take it
that [ __ ] serious and let that
cause come into your ego i guess you
know what i mean you'll be fine
you get over it yeah you get over it
right now sebastian has like a great uh
joke about it where he's like all the
trolls are on the internet are always
people that are just sitting in their
basement just on the computer
no actually they've done studies on it
it's actually not what you think it's
actually a lot of
regular citizens like teachers and
people
and i don't know if that's true oh i
don't think that's true
yes it is actually yes it is that can't
be true i can show you because because
teachers how many teachers do you think
are in america a lot now
so a lot how many teachers do you think
it's not just teachers what i'm saying
is that
people think it's like these guys and a
lot of it is a lot of social media
hate comes from people who for whatever
reason are bored at work
or they it would surprise you and they
go it's something inside them comes out
and they go
and so if you see the vast majority of
it i guarantee the vast majority
of facebook did a whole thing on this
like where they were like where is this
coming from
and it's not coming from these little
guys it's coming from a lot of people
you'd be surprised at
like people people are dicks when
nobody's looking it's it's the least
that's the thing
the least most productive people ever
though like
they're they're they're like it's no one
killing it in life that's leaving that
stuff that's what i'm saying i got i
don't
that's why i'm like a teacher someone
unhappy with their life a teacher a lot
of times like housewives
it's oh i don't know oh i mean all that
i could see the teacher i could see
the teachers i don't see that i'm saying
teachers are too busy
too busy i can't see the majority of
hate online people
from work is what i'm saying they're not
doing it from their basement they're
doing it from work
they're doing it from where they are so
they're doing it from a cubicle
they're doing it they just think it was
like it's not the prototypical
i'm in my basement my mom it's people in
the workforce who are like
bored yeah i'm going that bugs me you
know
yeah that's what i read yeah so
all right uh you're going to be you're
going to be in houston soon right
yeah there was a tiger on the loose in
houston
[Music]
i like that intro
i guess it was a little tiger though it
was a pet tiger someone had
and then they reported the night before
they couldn't find it and later on this
guy who's like an off-duty
um police officer tyra's walking calm to
him
like straight up to him
that would be scary that is either way
that'd be [ __ ] scary
you got kids walking around looking so
he's doing this tonight he said no sir
you don't know sir also why won't you
just get it in your trap
why is this guy he probably had his door
open
come on man do better with the video
dude nuts
so the guy yelling was like it's his
tiger
[Music]
oh if someone's tiger yeah this guy was
that loose he's like don't shoot him
don't you know i'll get him back
because i don't get to [ __ ] you i don't
care it's a [ __ ]
time yeah it's a [ __ ] tiger
jesus um t-grays are no joke
oh this i thought was funny
i'll just play for you this is from
barstool so i'm a [ __ ] and i hate
seeing other people happy especially
when they have nicer things than me
things i can't afford
so what i do is search instagram for
hashtags so let's say
sneakerheads i search sneakerhead easy
nike and i'll find
victims once i pick out somebody i find
their posts
and then i repost them but with an awful
shoe
usually a statue
that's so funny i would just repost them
and see how they reacted the first guy i
chose my first victim
took it not so well sent me a message
reported your account you'll be banned
soon
i wasn't and i kept going
fly [ __ ] only all black diameters
see some of these responses this [ __ ]
guy photoshopped skechers over my fog
skylines lol
i don't know what fog skylons are but
they're sketchers now stupid pranks
started to be on me because i was
spending hours and hours and hours
because this kid had like 35 pairs of
shoes and i
did them all this guy's
awesome so now that's funny that's
[ __ ] funny that's hilarious
god that's funny that's chill
damn that's hilarious i love it
um i could you know i wouldn't know oh i
wouldn't know what's cool with shoes i
don't know how you decide
you guys decide what's dope and what's
not i don't know
i don't know those are actually those
are actually [ __ ] cool
these these are sean weatherspoon adidas
those are pretty badass
yeah you but you got cool shoes from
suplex yeah yeah
they sent me some so that you're dope
you know why those are cool and some
other ones are not
these are uh and i never know what any
of the shoes are called but i just know
i i just go off like right
i go off like a look i don't go off if
it's like the hottest thing
or whatever these are badass that looks
like it looks like a shout out to suplex
it looks like a house architecture a
little architecture yeah yeah i can see
how you think that those are classics
you know they are
now could you play basketball on those i
can't play basketball they're basketball
shoes
probably wouldn't want to you're asking
the wrong guy about my racist
questions sorry about that yeah
i'm sorry to racially profile i'm just
saying they look like basketball shoes
they are basketball oh it's just some
crazy
instagram posts i saw with these dogs it
didn't look real
did he just kick it yeah and he does
this stuff that's a belgian
brandon you had one how crazy is that
the dog's doing parkour
yeah he catches a frisbee on the planet
yeah they're such beasts
they can they can scale a 12-foot wall
this is what kind of belgian malinois
and they and i've had them bite me on a
in a bite suit in afghanistan no punk
and it ain't fun check this alligator
yeah the alligator actually jumps up
almost like four feet it says
they'll eat a [ __ ] dog because your
dogs like to bark at everything oh yeah
there's no idea what's going on your
food
oh no yeah and he's in the water now
also figure it out dog dogs drive me
nuts
does he does he die no no he was saved
okay
and there you can see this guy running
so he was able to save him thank god
that [ __ ] alligator just grabbed him
i jumped and actually jumped out of the
water lucky i mean that's the thing
again
did you see where that old man saved his
puppy yeah from uh
this is what while smoking a cigarette
dogs all the [ __ ] time look
at how it jumps it actually jumps that
high yeah
he's in the water that's food did you
guys hear about the story about
uh some dude's dog was attacked by i
think
uh a bear the guy who ran at the bear
tackled the bear off his dog and started
feeding him shots to the heads it could
be
it wasn't it wasn't black bear uh yeah
it wasn't like a huge bear was like a
little one it was like a
juvenile like uh yeah smaller bird
barrel because that grizzly bear ain't
gonna
oh
uh go up i think that might
be it the top one i love dogs sometimes
you got chocolate
sometimes if they're crazy sometimes you
got a chocolate
yeah this is it that horror sunk in but
didn't paralyze him
i just ran down there plowed into the
bear tackled it and grabbed it by its
throat and started hitting it in the
face and i tell it let him go the bear
ran off
that's good that sucks oh [ __ ] oh wow
[ __ ] his face mother lode vet hospital
was ready for surgery as soon as caleb
got there
buddy neither if it was your kid has it
rescued him again
from a 350-pound bear yeah i don't
believe it
i know that's why it's tough to believe
these sometimes yeah you know what
i don't believe it's 350 and i also
don't believe he tackled and started
punching it and i have i think
he ran and scared the bears you know
what i'm going to take off
because it's going to be like this and
then also if you're like this that means
that
the that bear is is not i mean if you
see me just grab right in the center
you know how fast they are you grab
their neck and they turn you know strong
watch a bear they watch a small bear
turn on a woman you ever see a bear that
what that
that there was a um reporter
and she was doing a thing just go boom
and turns that was a big grizzly
it wasn't that big though if you look at
the bear it's like crazy
that's a huge that's what says 350 pound
bear yeah i don't think that was out
go is that the same one see he's three
fighters
yeah it's a reference for three hundred
feet he's grabbed him by the neck that
never
where's the neck never mind i'm just
kidding now this is what happened
this is what happened i was i think a
cub was playing with his dog and he
scared the cub off
that's what happened well the dog the
dog got beat up but it got bit but
whatever that bear was
yeah it's that's so sad jesus christ
that's it that's it
yeah that bear definitely [ __ ]
yeah i don't believe the story but i do
think some went down yeah a little fishy
yeah you don't think he was like
if your dog was in that situation would
you jump like the alligator like a bear
situation would you guys
the dog not if it's my kid kid yes my
dog
gotta get him dude you guys are
ruthless i want to live you want them to
go against the alligator
you ever seen a [ __ ] grizzly bear i'm
not
there's a million of them out there you
know as easy it is replace that
alligators are mad slow though have you
ever seen the show have you seen the
show gator voice
that's that salt yeah i wouldn't get in
the water with one i'd make it come out
if i have an alligator you funny dog
grabs you in the water you're in trouble
dude i will i will put my life on a line
for my dog
oh for i don't like how do you the hell
do you know
oh did i kind of tell you i have a
cavalier king charles spaniel
so if it gets if it gets taken by an
alligator there's
i don't think there will be much i can
do because they will be gone in one you
would die next that algae is like oh
look at this guy yeah look at this
little guy jump in the water
yeah like i said though i wouldn't get
in the water i'd i'd get something like
whack at it from like the thing oh cause
that's how they work yeah yeah so you're
gonna entice him out and hit him in the
head it doesn't come out
no no if it doesn't come out scare it
away but if it gets on the in the water
i'm [ __ ] on the ground i think i'll i
think i did
i love their faces
they're so fast on this show fast they
don't go for a long time but
they're they're so strong have you seen
gator boys
uh-huh i've seen the reality show on
[ __ ]
challenge yeah that's a reality show if
you ever heard me and brian's been
around some crocodiles
and and guess what dinosaurs well
they're dinosaurs
that is true yeah now that's a whole
different thing
salt water this one's just chilling
though what does that think
it's alligator just running afterwards
fish yeah they can run
they say running a zigzag
yeah because they can't turn their you
know what that's what they say
that's not that big there's only one way
to find out it's not big but it's big
enough and if it bites you the american
alligator has one of the strongest
plants on the planet
and then it drags you in the water and
rolls you yeah yeah yeah
yeah talk about the alligator room you
die the alligator roll
yeah because you ain't doing it don't
about the gator roll you can resist and
lose your arm maybe if you're lucky
you will yeah
here be dragon sir here be dragons
that's announced about over 2 000 pounds
you're a dragon
this is over two thousand pounds and i'm
a dragon yeah i know you know we're
still doing that
there you go oh man i'm saying bro i
felt it covered
i wish you didn't bring that up because
it didn't it didn't work dude
yeah i breathe fire anything else jen
just one last one
uh there's really nothing but jamie foxx
posted this and i thought it was funny
jimmy fox getting swole huh so
he just said swipe left but i don't see
anything other
why than him that face too okay well
what if we get all the way to the end
that's it
[Applause]
and that face too i don't know why he's
doing that face it looks fake
i think it's a filter i think he just is
he just advertising his glasses
he doesn't even say the glasses oh yeah
he does he has an eyeglass company he
does
yeah and he sells them for pretty cheap
yeah but it's the same glasses he's
wearing so
i thought maybe he had different glasses
on each picture but it's the same one
yeah and just those faces gorgeous
jeremy fox though yeah
he doesn't look that big there he's
supposed to he's playing mike tyson
so he supposedly put on a bunch of
weight he is
as talented as he gets yeah the best
such a beast
he won an award for that uh disney film
right
the soul did he win an award i think so
the first the movie one i don't think he
won the award oh he didn't win
the movie yeah like his character didn't
win got it
but yeah they won best animation
that was a great one too was he the
voice that was all right you thought it
was all right just all right
good for sure i thought onward should
have won
much more much more entertainment my
kids
that'll make you cry right onward to get
you gosh that'll get you
onward will get you man that ending whoo
it's just a film so not liking that oh
they they won the best animation they'd
be onward which
i don't [ __ ] is that it dude that's
it there we go
all right kids we did it we're yeah
brian we'll be camping we'll be back on
wednesday with
adam carolla yeah i'm excited nice
i'll see you in tampa kids um i'll be
actually i got a big and hungry live
podcast zany's
may 19th then may 21 22 tampa improv one
of my favorite places
now hold your breath brandon cause this
is gonna get exciting i'm gonna be in
toledo ohio oh wow at the funny bone now
i've never done it daddy daddy's in the
room yeah it's 28
are you doing a sunday too no no no no
take it easy i'm going to be there from
thursday
and i leave on sunday so i'll be third
thursday friday saturday
at the toledo funny bone don't know what
to expect i understand it's in a mall
we'll see what happens
uh toledo i don't know she got tampa
yeah toledo ohio's
you think i'm excited you're going back
you couldn't get enough going back you
go
going back um now chin what is there
doing toledo ohio
is there anything that that that one
would do in toledo fishing
fishing all right so they're ready look
for me i'll go to a zoo
after you watch that yeah i'll be in my
hotel room doing doing nothing
i'm in houston chappelle david lucas and
i
will all be in houston may 20th through
22nd
houston texas with the squad then
oklahoma city
brick bricktown comedy club june 10th
through the 12th tickets at fatkz.com
and then i'll be at goodnight's comedy
club in raleigh north carolina
this weekend may 13th through the 15th
tickets at chapelle lacy.com
or f a t k z too you're on there too
dot com fat all right kids you
love you bye